One thing I used to do, I used to play a
lot of basketball, right?
I would go up to gyms and just do open
runs. I had to stop going to one gym
because they turned it into a picture
fest. Everybody want to take f***ing
pictures. I ain't here to take pictures
here to play ball. I'm not coming back
to this gym. I go find another gym
where they do three on three basketball
Tuesdays and Thursdays, 6 a.m.
to 8 a.m.. It's much better.
That's what I need to be. It's more
intimate. Keep in mind, when I play
basketball, I'll talk a lot of s***.
F*** out of here, bitch.
You're too small. I'll put you in my
back pocket with your little ass.
You're too f***ing small.
Put you right in my back pocket.
I'm about to get buckets.
It's time to eat. Keep in mind when I
talk s***. I don't like it when you
don't talk s*** back. You're messing up
the competitive nature in the game.
If I talk s***, talk s*** back.
You playing three on three basketball?
They treat me like it's the goddamn NBA
calling plays, setting picks and s***.
It was too much. We lost.
I quit. I'm not playing anymore.
I walked out, there was a sign in the
lobby. The sign in the lobby said, Deaf
run Tuesdays and Thursdays, 6 a.m.
to 8 a.m.. Yeah.
They were deaf. They didn't hear s***.
I said now.
No, they didn't.
They weren't. They weren't calling
plays. They were communicating.
They were talking to one another.
Now, this isn't a joke about deaf
people. That's not what the joke is
about. It's about what I look like.
What the f*** did I look like back
there? Cause I know what I was saying.
I'm talking s***. Yeah. B****.
Yeah. B****. Yeah. You're too small.
Put you on my f***ing back pocket with
your little ass. Yeah.
Come on, b****. I'm about to get
buckets. Barbecue chicken.
That's what I said. What does that look
like without the volume? What does it
look like without the volume?
I just told that man I want to eat his
ass. That's what I just said.
I don't want to eat your ass.
That's barbecued chicken, bitch.
Barbecue chicken.
I'm not trying to eat your ass.
Had to leave a note. Apologize.